22nd and downtown Summerlin is the
perfect place to celebrate joining us
now to tell us more is their senior
marketing director Hayley harzinski
welcome welcome you guys have quite the
celebration and we have some fantastic
performers in studio that are going to
be doing some tricks for us while we
talk about it we have Jenna and Megan
here Nelson's going to join us shortly
tell us a little bit about what you have
going on for the Lunar New Year we are
so excited we have partnered with best
agency k-star training academy and then
the guanline Arts Association to bring
the best parade we've ever done and
we're so excited for this Sunday this is
gonna be fantastic so it's a parade and
performances tell us a little bit about
the parade and where that's going to be
absolutely so it'll be this Sunday uh
five o'clock the festivities will begin
so we'll have a little bit of
entertainment throughout the streets
some giveaways and then 5 30 the parade
will start promptly is there do you have
to pay to get in is it absolutely not
it's free open to the general public we
invite everybody to come out with their
families even if you haven't celebrated
Lunar New Year before it's a great
opportunity to show your kids some other
cultural celebrations and be part of it
it really is fun and these these
performers are so talented I mean Gemma
Megan what is going on that is
absolutely incredible now
um do you have any other things going on
for the Lunar New Year at downtown
Summerlin we do so we encourage everyone
to download our Summerlin app we will
actually have a giveaway the night of
the parade through our app as well as
during the week of Lunar New Year we'll
do Lucky Red Envelope giveaways so all
the information is on the Summerlin app
download it prior to Sunday and you'll
get all the scoop you guys are really
great we're gonna step back here because
these kids are so talented check this
out again we have Megan Gemma and Nelson
I don't know uh Haley do you think you
could pull this off I think we can maybe
try it later we'll see yeah you'll just
spot me oh absolutely incredible you
definitely want to check it out if you
haven't been to downtown Summerlin you
guys have a bit of everything down there
we do we have a variety of Decor too
that you can come on and check out a big
drying in our dining Royal and then also
the parade is sponsored by Kieran this
year so we'll have tastings on Sunday
from four to seven in the dining Arroyo
oh man just so much fun you guys always
bring it for every fun event thank you
guys thank you absolutely incredible
definitely want to check it out it's
happening in downtown Summerlin join in
on the fun the Lunar New Year parade is
happening 5 p.m January 22nd on Park
Center Drive if you need more
information go to summerlin.com